uh do you think you'll ever make a video
that gets 1 billion views I think maybe
one of the videos we've already made
might get a billion views which one do
you think probably like the the squid
game video with enough time I mean it's
only a year old and it's already on 300
million or some of the newer ones we've
done have gotten like 100 million views
in a month
um so those four projected over 10 years
because YouTube's not going anywhere
probably one of those so over time they
don't necessarily Plateau what's
interesting we're literally jumping
right now I love it it's good um so I
I'm a firm believer that it's much
easier to hypothetically get 10 million
views on one video than a hundred
thousand on a hundred and part of why
it's much easier in my opinion is like
if you make a really good video it's
just so Evergreen and it never dies
because YouTube when you open up YouTube
and look at the videos they're just
serving you whatever they think you'll
like the best you know and so if you
just make a great video and it's
constantly just above every other video
you know even two years down the road
then they'll just keep serving it never
stop you know which is why it's much
easier to make one great video than a
bunch of mediocre ones